[Музика]
добре, хлопці, я щасливий, що ви знову в
моєму класі, тому ми продовжуємо говорити про
Великобританію, і сьогодні ми збираємося
обговорити географічне положення та
клімат Сполученого Королівства, але перш
ніж почати наш урок, я  Я хотів би перевірити
свої домашні завдання, щоб у вас був цей
виклик, і вам потрібно було розшифрувати кожне
з підказкових слів, щоб тепер ви могли побачити
відповідь, тому підказки – це британська
історія, політика, щоденне життя та
стереотипи, а останнє слово –
фраза насправді  Фраза, яка допомогла
вам розшифрувати інші слова, -
Великобританія, добре, тож, до речі, які
стереотипи щодо британців у вас
є, чи що ви знаєте про
політику в цій країні чи про повсякденне
життя, і, можливо, ви знаєте про
британську історію,
тому ці  уроки допоможуть вам
глибше поглибити тему Великобританії,
і сьогодні ми збираємося обговорити
географічне положення та клімат
Британських островів, але перш ніж почати
читати, нам потрібно вивчити нову
лексику  добре,
тому порівняйте слова та фрази в
таблиці з їхніми визначеннями, щоб
перше слово було зроблено за вас, щоб перше слово було
чітко розрізненим і воно означало чітко окремі
та різні окремі окремі або
різні схожі на різні ідеї різні
добре друге слово хвалитися хвалитися
або  хвалитися, тому знайдіть визначення, і
це є чим пишатися
я хвалюся своїми дочками
я хвалюся своєю країною добре,
тоді буває рідко, рідко дуже мало
добре, спробуйте знайти синонім у
визначенні добре, і це невелике в
число і на великій території, тож у
вас є велика територія і дуже рідко дуже
мало, у вас є щось на цій ділянці
добре, наступна лежить лежить,
вона розташована, тому визначення: бути
в певному місці або позиції,
наприклад Україна  лежить у середині
Європи на Британських островах лежить на
півночі Європи добре, тому наступне слово
розташоване поруч із сусіднім з, а
визначення поруч із, щоб ви могли сказати
JSON - або ви можете сказати наступне  до Дана йде
Чилі, і в маршруті є
слово пагорб такий горбистий, і це означає, що
маєш багато частин вище, ніж навколишня земля, у тебе є долина
і пагорб, тому вся місцевість горбиста, добре,
а потім погойдується,
і це  означає, що переміщення навіть не складно,
іноді деякі райони в
різних країнах можуть бути дуже
нерівними, куди люди не ходять, тому
що місцевість там невідома,
і важко пройти через ці
землі, тому ці землі нерівні,
добре  наступний
складається з чогось, що складається з інших
папуг, добре,
і це означає бути перетворений або
сформований, тому ви можете подумати про це речення
про Сполучене Королівство Сполучене
Королівство складається з чотирьох країн, ок,
наступне
означає заклинання, і це означає короткі
періоди  певний тип погоди,
наприклад, восени, у нас є короткі
періоди сонячної погоди, яка називається «
базане літо», і останнє слово, очевидно,
переважає, означає, що дме в
певній місцевості  ce переважає бути в
певному місці та бути там переважно
добре ще раз слова виразний
хвастаються рідко лежать поруч із горбистим
рагда складається із заклинань і переважних
хлопців чи пам'ятаєш ти бій Quizlet, тож
, будь ласка, почніть створювати нову
порцію слів, які вам потрібні  для цього
блоку розділ про Великобританію, і ось перші
десять слів, які ви можете використати у своєму
Quizlet, щоб краще вивчити цей словниковий запас.
Добре, сьогодні ми допоможемо їм
виконувати завдання з читання, і ви знаєте, що
черга класу — гарний час, щоб почати отримувати
готові до ваших зовнішніх іспитів,
тому з цього моменту у нас будуть
завдання з читання та аудіювання,
які дуже схожі на ті, які ви
будете виконувати під час зовнішніх іспитів, і
я поясню вам, як краще
виконувати ці завдання та  як би у вас були
кращі результати, добре, тому перед читанням я
хочу, щоб ви подивілись на цю карту сьогодні,
начебто урок географії,
але англійською мовою, тож ми маємо
Сполучене Королівство Великої Британії та
N  Північна Ірландія, а ось окрема
країна, яка називається Республіка
Ірландія, це незалежна країна, тому
якщо - якщо - подивіться сюди, ви можете побачити
всю карту нашої півкулі, і ви можете
побачити місце Сполученого Королівства, яке
знаходиться на півночі -  захід над Європою, добре,
минулого разу я згадував такі острови,
як Шетландські або Оркнейські острови,
так, тут ви можете знайти деякі менші
острови, як-от Нормандські острови, Острови
Сціллі, і, звичайно, я хочу, щоб ви уважно подивилися
на цю карту та вивчіть її,
тому що ми "  Я збираюся читати про
географічне положення, тому майте на увазі, що
це дуже маленька країна під назвою
Уельс, і ви можете побачити, що в ній
багато гір, а ось Англія,
найбільша країна, і ви можете побачити, що
ця країна переважно зелена, тому це  означає,
ніби там є низовини і тільки
там гори на півночі Англії,
тоді ми маємо Шотландію, і знову в
Шотландії у вас буде два
окремих регіони: низовини та
високогір'я та йо  Ви повинні помітити, що зараз
в Ірландії більша частина землі є рівниною,
це Беліз
, і, що більше, Сполучене
Королівство найгірше за різними морями, тому ви можете
побачити Північне море, а ось це
Ірландське море, і ми маємо тут
Атлантичний океан так і Атлантичний океан
є чудовим джерелом тепла для
Сполученого Королівства, тому вивчіть цю
карту трохи, а потім ви зможете
прочитати текст добре, давайте рухатися далі,
тому географію та клімат,
будь ласка, дотримуйтесь  Коли я читаю, то що
таке Сполучене Королівство, щоб дати йому повну
назву, це Сполучене Королівство Великої
Британії та північні острови,
ви можете почути, що його називають Британією
Великобританією або частіше просто
як Велика Британія, чотири країни складають Велику Британію
Англія Уельс  Шотландія та Північна
Ірландія складається з групи
островів, двох великих і кількох
сотень менших, оскільки найбільший
острів поділений на
три країни Англія Уельс і
Шотландія, цей острів має приблизно 700 миль
л.  Він має 300 миль, а в найширшій
точці та найближчій точці лише 22
милі протоки Ла-Манш відокремлюють його
від узбережжя Франції, добре, давайте перейдемо
на столицю Англії Лондон також є
столицею Великобританії. Більша частина Англії
складається з низовини  з деяким
гірським рельєфом на північний захід від лінії,
проведеної між лиманом Хамбера на
сході та річковими дугами на південно-заході
Уельсу, а його столиця Кардіфф живе
на заході і має берегову лінію, прилеглу
до повітряного Ірландського моря, воно більш гористе,
ніж Англія, але
на півночі  і зустріти Уельс на півночі є
Шотландія, яка складається з двох дуже
різних регіонів, відомих як Хайленд
і низовини, регіон Хайлендс знаходиться
на півночі та заході країни і
є набагато більш гористим, ніж його
низовина сестра, скелястий рельєф
Хайлендс забезпечує  регіон малонаселений
привіт, ми можемо переміщатися по низинах. У регіоні
проживає більшість населення Шотландії,
він тут, тоді як столиця Шотландії
Единб  urg і найбільше місто Глазго бу
е знайдено через Ірландське море, перенесе на
на острів, на якому лише пі
нічно-східний кут Північна Ірландія є ча
тиною Великобританії, решта цього острова є о
ремою країною Республіка Ір
андія Північна Ірландія зі ст
лицею  Белфаст – це горбистий регіон
із найбільшим внутрішнім
водоймом у Великобританії, на площі 150 квадратних
миль, переважаючий вітер, як правило, дує
з південного заходу, приносячи з собою
часті періоди м’якої, але вологої погоди
з Атлантичного океану загалом,
хоча клімат досить досить  помірний і
схожий на більшу частину Північної Європи
добре, який довгий текст, але я майже
впевнений, що тепер ви зможете виконати всі
завдання, хлопці, завдання полягає в тому, щоб знайти
правильну відповідь, це завдання з кількома варіантами,
що я хочу, щоб ви  робіть, коли у вас
є паперова копія тексту, і
ви працюєте з паперовою копією. Я хочу, щоб у вас
були ваші олівці щоразу, коли у
вас виникне таке запитання, де ви
повинні вибрати, будь ласка, спробуйте  знайдіть точну
відповідь у тексті та підкресліть її, тоді
під час виконання тесту ви будете на 100% впевнені,
що вже знайшли правильну
відповідь, тож давайте прочитаємо питання, що
Сполучене Королівство містить сотню
малих островів, сотні маленьких островів,
тисячі  малі острови, а
правильна відповідь – сотні маленьких
острівців, давайте подивимося на текст
і знайдемо речення, яке показує нам
правильну відповідь, ось ця частина
тексту, і ви можете побачити речення, яке
доводить відповідь червоним і підкресленим
і  там сказано, що вона складається з групи
островів, двох великих і кількох
сотень менших,
що є синонімом сотень кілька
сотень один два три кілька добре
наступний Англія складається переважно з
низовини з кількома горами Високогір'я
та низовини, гори та низовини, добре,
тут  правильна відповідь – низовина
з кількома горами, давайте знову подивимося
на текст, і якби у вас був паперовий примірник,
я б попросив вас підкреслити його так, щоб він був
текст, що більша частина Англії
складається з низовини з деяким
гірським рельєфом, а ось
синонім до Highlands, як гірська
місцевість на північний захід від лінії, проведеної
між лиманом Хамбера на сході
та річковими дугами на північному заході, добре,
наступне питання Highlands of
Scotland  у нас мало людей і багато
гір багато людей на кількох горах
багато людей і багато гір
правильна відповідь - кілька людей і багато
гір, нам потрібно знайти синонім
у тексті, який говорить нам, що лише кілька
людей живуть там через багато
гір, візьмемо  подивившись на цю
частину тексту, тут написано, що
пересічений рельєф, який
ви повинні запам’ятати килими, дуже складно,
і ви не можете легко пройти через цю місцевість,
тому дуже хита місцевість
Високогір’я гарантує, що регіон малонаселений,
малонаселений означає дуже мало
населених  тож мова йде про людей, і ми
можемо сказати, що багато гір у вас є
скелястими, але мало людей в порядку,
наступна більшість людей у Шотланії  я живу
у високогір'ї, у горах у
низинах. Добре, вам потрібно пам'ятати, що
Хайлендс — це гірська місцевість,
і тому це переганяє їх у
гори, а не низовини — це низька
місцевість, де люди переважно живуть у таких
містах, як Единбург та  Глазго, тож
правильна відповідь знаходиться в низинах, і
знову давайте подивимося та
підкреслимо правильну відповідь у тексті, тому в
рівнинному регіоні проживає
більшість населення Шотландії, це означає, що
більшість людей живе там нормально,
наступний регіон Атлантичний океан  приносить багато
над холодною вітряною погодою волога, але не надто
холодна погода і холодна і волога погода,
так яку погоду ви пам'ятаєте,
щоб вона була волога, але не дуже холодна погода
тепла погода і в тексті сказано,
що переважні вітри
це означає вітри  цей удар,
як правило, надходить з цього південно-заходу,
приносячи з собою часті періоди
м’якої, але вологої погоди з Атлантичного
океану, часті періоди, впевнені, що це періоди
часу з дуже пл.  хороша погода, добре,
зараз друге завдання, вам потрібно зіставити
цифри в коробці, щоб зробити факти
про Великобританію, щоб у вас були різні числа,
наприклад 22 304 702 і 150, тож перше
речення кількість миль, що
відділяють найбільший острів від Франції
пам'ятати, що це дуже вузьке, і це
всього 22, добре, другий довжина
в милях найбільшого з островів Великобританії,
довжина добре, і це, хлопці, 700
добре, тоді кількість окремих регіонів у
Шотландії окремо означає,
що це лише дві низовини та  Хайлендс
добре, тоді цей розмір у квадратних
милях найбільшого внутрішнього
водоймища, чи пам’ятаєте ви ім’я Локк, ні,
і він становить 150, а максимальна ширина в
милях найбільшого острова у Великобританії становить
300 миль, а останнє
число  країн, які входять до
Сполученого Королівства, і це єдине
число, що залишилося, і це 4, чи можете ви назвати
їх Англія Шотландія Уельс та Північна
Ірландія
добре, давайте рухатися далі, і час для нашої п’ятої
години gramma T, так що thi  Коли ми
будемо говорити про минуле досконале,
що це таке, коли ви розповідаєте історію,
іноді необхідно розповісти про
дії, які відбулися до деяких інших
дій у минулому, і ви повинні використовувати
past perfect, щоб виразити час, коли
ці  дії відбулися, тому як його утворити
ми утворимо простий минулий досконалий час з had
і not, якщо необхідно і третя
форма дієслова, наприклад head gun
had been seen okay, а ключові слова є
після і перед ще раз я хочу, щоб ви
звернули увагу  що ми будемо говорити про
дві дії в минулому,
одна з яких відбулася до іншої,
знову в минулому, добре, так що подивіться на
ці речення, їй потрібна допомога, тому що
хтось вкрав її автомобіль, що сталося
спочатку, хтось викрав її автомобіль, а
потім  їй потрібна допомога друге речення
він пройшов тест, тому що він
багато починав діяти в минулому, він
почав і він успішно пройшов, але перед тим, як
почати, він почав і тільки зробив, він
пройшов
тест наступне речення після  вона зробила своє
домашнє завдання, вона відвідала мене,
тому перша дія тут полягає в тому, що вона
зробила своє домашнє завдання, а потім вона прийшла до
мене, добре, наступне, коли я прийшов додому,
вони вже поїли,
тому перша дія
тут полягає в тому, що вони щось з'їли
і  тільки потім я повернувся додому, тоді вони
продали все, перш ніж вони переїхали в
Глазго, тому спочатку вони повинні були продати
все, і вони зробили це, і тільки потім
вони переїхали в Глазго, перша дія
тут,
добре, давайте спробуємо, щоб практика стала ідеальною,
тому після того, як вони відкриють вікно  стало
холодніше,
що є першою дією, звичайно, спочатку
вам потрібно відкрити вікно, потім повітря
в кімнаті зміниться, тому після того, як
вони відкрили вікно
, стало холодніше, перша дія відкрилася
стала другою дією, так що
наступне після нас  подивись фільм ми лягаємо спати
яка тут перша дія так,
звичайно, дивитися фільм або дивитися
фільм, а потім ти лягаєш спати, так перше
і друге місце за кордоном і що
ти маєш після того, як ми побачили  фільм, ми
лягли спати добре, наступне місце,
коли він пішов, вона почала плакати, тому
спочатку він полюбив, а потім вона почала
плакати,
і щоб зробити це одним реченням після того, як він
пішов, вона почала плакати, і знову
це минуле ідеальної форми показує  ми, що
це перша дія в минулому, а
потім наступає
друга дія, що вона почала плакати
добре, хлопці, я думаю, що ви готові
до свого запиту про втулку, і ви
готові зробити це вдома, ось закони цих
речень  з вправи, яку ми почали
виконувати разом, ваше завдання полягає в тому, щоб розкрити
дужки з використанням минулого простого та
минулого ідеального шансу,
тож давайте переглянемо речення,
як тільки кожна місцевість буде її парасолькою, тож
яка перша з них так, звичайно,
почався дощ і  потім вона взяла
парасольку, тож у цій частині, яка повертається
, ви б використали минуле ідеальне, добре, давайте
подивимось, нехай додамо речення номер дев'ять,
перш ніж ми вийдемо ми взуємо наші нові черевики, чи
можна вийти без черевиків, ні,
ви повинні їх одягнути  спочатку  а потім
виходите, але як показати це, використовуючи
часи тут, ви б використали right past
perfect добре, гм, переглядайте, тож давайте
подивимося на останній добре, він
їсть пиріг після того, як запитав, тож чи він
ввічлива людина, ніж  спершу, звичайно,
він запитав, і лише потім він їв, тож
він як би ви сказали, що він з'їв пиріг
після того, як запитав, тому я даю вам кілька
підказок, я дав вам кілька, я б сказав,
навіть правильні відповіді, тож, будь ласка,
закінчіть робити все це  речення та
не соромтеся надсилати їх мені поштою або
зв’язуватися зі мною через Instagram
[Музика]
добре, хлопці, сьогодні у нас був дуже
інформативний урок про
географічне положення та клімат
Сполученого Королівства Великої Британії та
Північна Ірландія ми розглянули нову тему граматики,
і я сподіваюся, що я дав вам достатньо
підказок і навіть правильних відповідей, щоб бути
готовим до виконання домашнього завдання,
не соромтеся надсилати їх на мою електронну пошту або
зв’язуватися зі мною через Instagram, до
наступного разу слідкуйте за оновленнями
[Музика  ]
ти